[Music]
[Applause]
eddie johnson the sun's color analyst
for valley sports arizona co-host of nba
today on nba radio
and as the kids like to say when he
played he could fill it up
eddie joins us on the program eddie uh
thanks for joining us
uh if you were going to pinpoint one
thing is the reason why the clippers won
what would you say yeah dan first of all
thanks for having me you know you
you've been my hero in radio forever so
i'm not just saying that
uh now what was your first question i
got all discombobulated because i'm so
happy to be here with you
uh you're on the golf course
yes i am oh okay um all right
i won't take it too much of your time
then uh okay
if you're gonna pinpoint what what's the
reason why the clippers won this game
all right it was game three i mean you
think about it dan they're down too old
uh historically that game three is
always the toughest game
uh it's an embarrassing game if they
lose that game they're not coming back
in the series no team has ever come back
from 3-0
so you expected them to come out and
play like their life was on the line
uh and that they had to do everything to
win the game so
the suns didn't come out with the energy
that that matched what the clippers
desperation was and
the clippers won the game i never
thought this would be a sweep
although the sun's at one nine in a row
uh you had to feel like they were going
to run into a mini wall
and that mini wall happened last night
devin booker playing with that mask on i
don't know if you've ever played with a
mask on but
guys we'll talk about it's just
uncomfortable and
yes um so i i'm gonna guess that had
something to do with a
subpar performance but yeah but but how
dare you bring that up right then
because
you know historically you know people
they're very
uh careful with guys that are very good
at certain things
for instance patrick beverly is known as
a tremendous defender
and so after game one did you hear any
quotes that devin booker wore out
patrick beverly
he didn't hear any quotes all you heard
was devin booker had a great game
yeah so patrick beverly's protected and
so
now when patrick when devin booker
struggles everybody says oh well patrick
beverly
and i'm like hold up now it doesn't work
that way
what about devin booker was just off
because devin booker faces intense
defense
every night every night they're building
their defense to stop him
there's nothing unusual he's just been
off the last two games and he has to get
better
yes i think the mass has presented a
problem for him
but as always he said about offensive
players and i was no offensive player
nobody ever stopped me they made me work
harder but they didn't stop me
i thought my offense was gonna become
their defense and i think
the sun's got a little lax last night i
think devin has to
really find his creases better uh than
he did in the first game
and they'll be fine but give the
clippers credit i mean
we know defensively they can turn it up
as a team and i thought they did
their energy was there uh and devin
can't say woe is me
i mean you know this this thing with the
mask he's got to find a way to get over
it as chris paul
got over his shoulder in the first
series against the lakers i mean
you just can't let that bother you and i
don't think devin is i just think he has
been off the last two games could be
fatigued
could be you know just the length of the
playoffs in its run
uh but he'll be fine i guarantee you he
can he i've never seen him go three
straight games
i was also wondering this prior to last
night's game
do you bring chris paul off the bench
now i know campaign tweaked his ankle
but
but i did like what he was doing when he
was in there
and i thought this allowed chris to ease
into the lineup
uh do you think that would have been a
better way to go not that you could have
kept chris on the bench i'm guessing but
right i understand right yeah yeah you
know it
it's just difficult i mean look he's all
nba
he's basically the reason that lifts
this team up to the level it's been at
i think if anything chris paul would
have had to be the one to go to monty
and say hey bring me off the bench
okay you know because i don't think
monty would have done that
uh but yeah i mean 11 days off
and and look i had copic so i know what
it can do to you you can't work out
uh you can't you know you did say don't
exert yourself
so i know he's not in pristine shape you
can see last night he was short on his
jump shot the shots that he got were the
shots that he got against denver
it wasn't their defense i mean he and
devin booker missed a lot of open shots
shots that they normally make
and yeah i thought he was dragging a
little bit and he'll be better
in game four but yeah the pace has to
pick up dan if anything
campaign really has a great pace to his
game
uh and that's why the combination of he
and chris paul are very good
and uh chris has to push the ball i
think early in game four
what do you what do you see out of paul
george
you know i've been knowing paul since
he's 17 years old my son and he
both went to fresno state uh i love him
i've mentored him over the years
he's a tremendous young man and i think
people really look at him the wrong way
at times
he's an honest guy he actually says
what's on his mind
and he's extremely talented and he's
having fun being batman
it's not easy being robert and and
that's what he has been really in his
his last two stops since he left indiana
you know although he had got mvp
consideration oklahoma city
he was still robbing to westbrook and
he's robbing to kawhi
and when you're robbing you you hesitate
at times
you know you feel more pressure now he's
loose i mean he's the guy
he can do everything dribble it up take
shots
took 26 last night didn't worry about
being off
i mean if he was robbing and then kawhi
was playing
and kawhi was rolling and he was
struggling you might see hesitation in
this game as we've seen that
with this duo so i love paul george i
think he's tremendous and the sons have
to do some things to stop him and slow
him down
because he can be the difference in the
series he's eddie johnson the sun's
color analyst for
valley sports arizona co-host of nba
today on nba radio and a
former great scorer in the nba you know
you mentioned that about
batman and robin i brought that up with
uh ben simmons
i think ben would be better elsewhere
because he has played better more
comfortably
when joel embiid was out he was a
different player
and yes i so i could see that is a
reason why if i'm ben
that i do want to get out maybe i'm not
going to win anything anytime
soon but i need to start over i need to
hit the reset button for my career
maybe he gets confident maybe he he
starts to get a little better shooting
uh form there but what do you think of
that logic
he dropped 40 on go bear with him beat
out yeah
that's the biggest example uh very
aggressive offensively because he knows
now it's on his shoulders
you know when embiid is there he defers
to him rightly so
but he's uncomfortable in doing it it
takes him out of rhythm
i totally agree with you he needs to get
to a team where everything
is on his shoulders and then he's forced
to do some things he doesn't like to do
i heard you mention scotty pippen you
know in regards to he and kd
and if you remember scotty was robbing
to to jordan obviously and they won
titles
but the one year that scottie was able
to be batman
he made all lead and a really a phantom
foul away from
maybe getting back to the finals and
then i know you brought up the ku koch
situation well that's why
scotty was upset because all of a sudden
scotty went back to that thought where
when jordan was there he never got that
chance now jordan's gone and he's been
batman all year
phil wants to let kuko take the shot and
it
it just it hit him in a way that you
know
yeah but eddie that doesn't make sense
because mike was there when
paxton hit the shot against the suns and
mike was there when steve kerr hit a big
shot against the utah exactly
exactly but it took him a quarter to
finally throw the ball to paxton
because field kept telling him to throw
it okay
and then he had to like put uh steve
kerr under under under a court pressure
where he kept asking him you're gonna be
ready
you're gonna be ready to shoot before he
gave it to him okay
no you're right but that's michael that
we know we know mike's competitiveness
there but
if i said you could have durant as a
teammate or pippin as a teammate
for me in david for me and and this is
why i say this because to me magic is
the best
ever and i think when lebron retires i
think lebron will be
and here's why because you know me dan
what was i
as a player i was the guy that depended
on what depended on my teammates
i mean my success was dependent on guys
that got me open and guys that got me
the ball
well magic and lebron are two of the
best ever getting you the ball
and still getting there whereas with
with kd or with
mj i'm watching just like paxton and
curry was watching
so you know we all have different
eyesight in regards to who we would like
to play with or who we think is the best
and for my money i would take scotty
because i know scotty is going to
involve the entire team
and no disrespect to kevin durant he's
an unbelievable basketball player man i
love watching him
uh but that's how i would view it
do you think lebron can end up as the
best player of all time
i do i actually do i think he's got to
win another title or two
to do it uh but i do he's won he's
trumped him and he's trumped everybody
in every record
i mean he's got everything longevity
records
he's the most one of the most unselfish
players to ever play and he might wind
up
beat all-time lead scoring his game and
top five and top five
isn't that amazing i don't know i don't
care yeah the 6-0 is always going to be
there as a shadow over him but scottie
pippen six you know
give me you know it's a team it's a team
record give me your michael jordan on
the court
story the most tenacious dude i've ever
encountered in my life
is there a story though that did uh oh
yes oh yes
indiana pacers the year that they were
trying to they were trying to win 73
instead of 72
well we were playing them at the end of
the year and really
nobody really needed the game it was
just a game we were playing
but i knew that they wanted to get 73
and
it was a close game it was in the fourth
quarter and i think we were up six
and i was in the game and i looked at
him i said i guess you all not getting
73
and he just looked at me and he started
chewing his gum real fast
and i'm like okay and for the next
minute and a half
he lost his mind i mean it was like it
was game seven
and he fouled me at the end on a jumper
and they called a foul hit me on the
elbow and i had two free throws to seal
the victory and he was just
mad and he was walking off the court and
he and i was like crossing paths i said
man what is wrong with you
he said just be careful what you act
[Laughter]
uh it's great to catch up with you eddie
and uh
thank you thank you enjoy your round of
golf there all right thank you very much
that's uh eddie johnson sons color
analyst
that's not a bad life there you know
getting ready to play golf
early in the morning uh he's co-host of
nba today on nba radio as well